at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking this episode of the tim ferriss
show is brought to you by linked in the
write higher can make a huge impact on
your business the wrong hire can create
your business and I have seen example
after example from thousands of my
readers at a minimum where they've told
me stories of how finding the right
person at the right time and in some
cases not even asking what should I do
but asking who should I find because
that person can help me determine what
exactly to do more intelligently and
I've had a chance to hire two such
people
in the last year and that has just made
my business take a quantum leap forward
and my complexity in my personal and
business life get cut dramatically and
this type of simplification cannot be
overvalued we think a lot about hiring
and I think a lot about hiring and it is
a skill that I've had to learn it is
important to find the right person but
where do you find that person you can
post a job on a job board and hope that
that right person finds your job that
they are on the Internet happening to
scan something here and there and then
find you but think about it how often do
you hang out on job boards the answer is
probably not very often so don't leave
finding someone great to chance when you
can post your job exactly where people
go every day to make connections grow in
their careers and discover job
opportunities that is linked in most
LinkedIn members haven't recently
visited the top job boards but 9 out of
10 members are open to new opportunities
and with 70% of the US workforce
on LinkedIn posting there is the best
way to get your job opportunity in front
of more of the right people and you can
be very very highly targeted and
specific people who are qualified for
the role you have and ready for
something new
is where you find them it's the best way
to find that person that key person who
will help you grow your business and
this is why a new hire is made every ten
seconds using LinkedIn that's bonkers
every ten seconds so head to
linkedin.com forward slash Tim and get
$50 off your first job post that's a
linkedin.com forward slash Tim T I am to
get $50 off your first job post LinkedIn
comm forward slash Tim take a look
terms and conditions do apply this
episode is brought to you by peloton
which I've been using probably about a
year now peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right into your home you
can also do on-demand which is what I do
we'll come back to that so you don't
have to worry about fitting classes into
a busy schedule or making it to a studio
or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute I for instance have a peloton
bike right in my master bedroom at home
and it's one of the first things I do
many mornings I wake up I meditate for a
bit then I knock out a short 20 minute
ride in my undies hard to do that at the
gym take a shower and I'm in higher gear
for the rest of the day it's really
convenient and has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip-hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to
do on-demand and listen to a lot of and
watch many of the same classes over and
over but I'm kind of promiscuous and
also enjoy classes from a lot of the
other instructors they have peloton an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I didn't
think that it would work
or in any way incentivize me but they
really 100% hit the nail on the head I
was very very impressed with how
motivating it was I know work
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out
discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings the studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
calm that's o-n-e
peloton PE l oto and.com and enter the
code Tim all caps at checkout and get
$100 off of accessories with your policy
on bike purchase so get a great workout
at home anytime you want check it out go
to one peloton calm and use the code Tim
to get started
why hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is my
job each episode to deconstruct tease
out the habits and routines best
practices life lessons and so on from
world-class performers from many many
different disciplines my guest today is
Jim Collins and this is a rare treat
because Jim very very seldom does any
media or interviews whatsoever I have
wanted to speak with him for more than a
decade in fact and it was worth the wait
this conversation over delivered on
every level I can imagine and I really
hope you enjoy it as much as I did so
who is Jim Collins this mysterious
reclusive mastermind polymath Jim
Collins is a student and teacher of what
makes great companies tick and a
Socratic advisor will get a better idea
of what that means particularly in the
beginning of the interview where he
wants to ask me questions so we do get
to Jim's story but he wants to and
wanted to even before we started
recording ask me a few questions so let
me get back to the bio he is student and
teacher of what makes great companies
tick and that is an understatement he
really has as delved into the data and a
Socratic advisor to leaders in the
business and social
sector's he's authored or co-authored
eight books that have together sold more
than 10 million copies worldwide that's
a lot of books including good - great
good degrade in the social sectors built
to last how the mighty fall gripped by
choice and his newest work turning the
flywheel which gets into all sorts of
details about the self-perpetuating in
some ways models behind Amazon Vanguard
and so on fascinating concept and very
practical examples driven by a
relentless curiosity which you will get
front-row seats for Jim began his
research and teaching career on the
faculty at the Stanford Graduate School
of Business where he received the
distinguished teaching war in 1992 in
1995 he founded a management laboratory
in Boulder Colorado in 2017 Forbes
selected Jim as one of the 100 greatest
living business minds and we talked
about not just what makes good companies
great we get into that a bit but really
worth digging into Jim in himself we
talk about how he tracks time how he
breaks up his day his sleep optimization
his stories related to Peter Drucker
which are just amazing and so on and so
forth he's also as I might have already
inferred multifaceted multi-talented
he's an avid rock climber as one example
and has completed single-day a sense of
El Capitan and Half Dome in Yosemite
Valley and if you don't know what that
means just take my word for it it's very
impressive you can find more about Jim
at Jim Collins com and now without
further ado please enjoy and I certainly
enjoyed it please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with none
other than Jim Collins
Jim welcome to the show I'm really happy
to be here and I'm hoping that you
wouldn't mind if I start by exercising a
bit of my own curiosity just to ask you
some questions to begin our conversation
I would I would love to jump into it any
way that you would like so I'm game for
questions so I am dying to ask what did
you do your Princeton senior thesis on
my senior thesis which took some extra
time to complete was on the the phonetic
and semantic acquisition of Chinese
characters by native English speakers
and it was looking at language
acquisition but specifically what most
people in the West would consider
ideograms and there are a few different
layers of meaning or context for each
character that one might acquire so the
thesis was about the different
approaches the pros and cons of various
methods for acquiring these characters
and what is language acquisition it's a
it's a two major I've never quite heard
of and I'd be curious what its essence
is so within the East Asian Studies
department yet you had to pick a primary
language and I I chose Japanese because
I had spent a year in high school in
Japan going to a Japanese school as an
exchange student but I ended up taking
primarily Chinese classes because my
Japanese level was already decently high
and within the context of that
department language acquisition would be
focusing on and this is really good it's
a it's a very good question
because the way that I look at language
is really acquiring concepts and a
almost an operating system for thinking
that is associated with a different
culture and that would generally in say
a language like Chinese and most
languages start with the phonemes the
sounds themselves and in the case of
something tonal like
mandarin you're actually going to be
doing a lot of training it's almost like
going to the gym and lifting weights
because to produce a sound like or a
word like yes you which is maybe or if
you wanted to ask with a retroflex of
tongue not sure how much searching like
what is that thing you you really need
to develop musculature that you have not
developed before as a native english
speaker and then after you've developed
the basic the basic phonetics and
pronunciation verbally you would move
into the writing and for some scripts
and the writing tells you a lot about
the thinking of a given culture and I
think if culture is sort of a collection
of shared beliefs and habits because
some are are purely phonetic like we
have our romanized alphabet and then
others have multiple layers like Chinese
where you have a character that's
composed of radicals each of which has a
particular connotation in terms of in
terms of meaning and the etymology so
all of that is those would all
comprising greedy n't sin the recipe
that is language acquisition and and and
forgive me for asking you a follow-up
question on that I'm just I'm curious
just as you've clearly come from both a
love of language but also a study of
language how much do you think the
language in which you are operating
whether that be mathematics or whether
it be Japanese or Chinese or English
either constraints or or enhances the
concepts that we develop I would say
almost completely I think the he I can't
remember if it was the Vidkun Stein who
said the what is it the limits of our
language or the limits of our world or
something else to that to to that effect
I feel like language and thinking are
inseparable and therefore part of the
appeal to me in
acquiring other languages studying other
languages even if I only use them
temporarily like I did when I visited
Turkey or Greece these places I still
study the languages very intensely
because it gives you in my experience a
different lens through which to process
the world and to absorb stimuli and to
react to things differently so so in my
experience you can you can you can very
often tell a lot about someone by not
just the language they speak but the
particular dialect within that language
that they choose so that that can apply
to English and the particular nuances or
predilection someone has in their own
save grammar vernacular even in a given
family but it can also apply to coding
and then within coding you have
different coding languages and they tend
to reflect in many instances different
personalities and different value
systems different priorities so that's
that's how I would I was thinking about
that yeah you mentioned vit consign I I
am a no expert on bit consent I had a
quarter in college which the main focus
of the work I was learning in was in big
consign and I remember the professor
saying to me well what's marvelous about
big [ __ ] Stein is he said something along
the lines of he lays out very clinically
what we can meaningfully talk about and
and then the professor and of course
then there's the great punchline which
is that most of what's really important
we can't talk about so because because
the words can't go to the mystical so
very very interesting and I've often
thought about this one I wrestle with
concepts as I'm wrestling in my own
research what are the first questions I
ask people often ask me well so how do
you how do you develop a concept or how
do you decide to comment something that
would allow you to say you know
articulate something you're seeing
through the lens of say the level 5
hierarchy or the preserve the course to
relate progress duality
whatever first question I always ask
myself is what's the conceptual vessel
right because to get a concept you
there's different kinds of concepts
right you've got dialectics you've got
hierarchies you have stages you have
equations you have categories right and
one of the first most important things
to do is to say well if you're looking
at something what's what's the best kind
of conceptual vessel and then from there
you develop the concept and just one
thing on language it's not really about
language per se it's about the really
hard world of writing and as I was
looking about your background Tim I
noted if I read it right that you had
crossed paths with one of our great
nonfiction writers John McPhee is that
right that is correct I was very very
lucky and got to take a class called the
literature of fact which was a seminar
that McPhee used to teach I don't know
if he still teaches it but that I did
have a chance to spend some time with
the incredible McPhee
yeah and just before we launch into our
broad conversation I I what what was it
like to have a class from McPhee I mean
I have never met McPhee but I've been a
huge almost student of how he writes
course and I love the most recent work I
think it's called draft number four
where he describes to all of us who
struggle with words yeah the struggle of
writing but he's got those great books
from years ago a sense of where you are
about Bill Bradley and he has the
Archdruid book and he has the control of
nature which recently with all of the
fires and so forth happening in
California actually went back to read to
kind of remind myself how McPhee was
writing about these things before and
and and he had just such a marvelous way
of being able to use words to really
exercise his curiosity and see things
and then put them in these marvelous
forms and I've often thought boy if you
could like learn from him how to write
so as a proxy for the
what what would you you know as those of
us who write we all know how hard
writing is right nobody would ever say
writings fun what uh what do you what
did you take from from McPhee being able
to really learn directly from him I
never get tired of talking about McPhee
although I worry about invoking his name
in a sense because I feel like I'm such
a shameful repetitive writer full of all
sorts of fluff compared to his type
prose is the consummate version of that
Twain lying about you know the
difference between almost the right word
and the right word is the difference
between a lightning bug and a lightning
bolt right so I so with with the with
the sort of preface that I in no way
compare myself to McPhee or claimed to
have had all of his magic rub off on me
the class was it was absolutely this is
this is me looking for the right word
looking for the lightning and not the
lightning bug it what I don't use this
expression much but it was really
paradigm shifting for me and in many
respects when it came to writing and
thinking and I'll mention a few things
before I directly answer your question
number one is I've carried my notes from
that class with me everywhere Oh meaning
in every place I have lived since I took
the class which would have been in
probably 98 or 99 so I've been carrying
these notes for 20 years now so that
should tell you about how highly I value
them the the second is I remember very
clearly when we had our first round of
feedback on some initial writing tasks
that we had been assigned maybe was we
had three I think it was like three to
five page writing assignments each week
and we would have a seminar with all the
students together and then we would have
one-on-one sessions with McPhee and I
remember the first time he handed out in
class the read
and versions of our assignments so the
the the printouts with his red ink on
them and in almost every case he he led
into it by saying I just want you to
know before I hand these back that you
are all good writers so I don't want you
to take this or take this the wrong way
or something like that and there was
more red ink on the page than black ink
and over time he it was it was
remarkable how how quickly you could
hone your observation to identify
superfluous words to identify the fat on
the sentences that you're putting on the
page and what ended up happening I
should say that's on the micro level on
the macro level and we can come back to
this and I do have questions about your
conceptual vessel comment earlier it was
structure it was it was thinking about
structure visually that really changed
the game for me with respect to all
types of writing and if for those people
who do like to get into the weeds I
think that draft number four gives
plenty of examples of how intricately he
thinks about structure and he did a
number of interviews with the parish
review on nonfiction writing which are
also really worth reading but my grades
in every other class went up and yes
it's multifactorial there are all sorts
of other things that that could have
contributed but the the the correlation
between starting that class and all of
my other grades improving and all of my
other classes was really uncanny and I
think that is very specifically because
it was it was tightening up my thinking
and it was forcing me to on a weekly
basis justify the use of specific words
and McPhee is a real stickler for the
right word yeah and if you use something
that is vague that seems like a
lazy backup option that you tented to
default to a lot he will spot that very
very quickly and it was a wonderful
wonderful class and he is a very
entertaining teacher as well it's not
like having a clinical autopsy done of
your work each week although he is also
very dispassionate and certainly not
trying to just make you feel good with
his feedback but he over the years has
developed a very entertaining style I
remember at one point he was riffing on
the various ways that one can convey he
said or she said and he and he brought
up the very real example when people say
no she ejaculated and he just you know
went on this riff about how unnecessary
that was and I got a good chuckle out of
the students of course because there was
a lot of heavy lifting to come 20
minutes later when we were going to
actually jump into some type of task so
it's a long answer but McPhee is along
with a handful of other people I can
point to very specifically one of the
people who has had the biggest impact on
my writing but more importantly on like
thinking and how I think about
structured thought and and I want to say
one thing about Vidkun Stein really
quickly before I forget and that is many
of Russians had many but a surprising
number of the people I respect for clear
thinking have an affinity for
Wittgenstein Reid Hoffman the co-founder
of LinkedIn would be another example of
that and I think that's worth mentioning
just because I think philosophy there's
certain categories or labels of the
fields of study that sometimes get
pushed to the wayside as impractical and
I think the study of language and the
concepts that language represent is
extremely extremely valuable I mean it's
kind of one step above consciousness if
we're looking at
like the foundational layers upon which
everything else is built so let me ask a
question if I may and thank you for
letting me start with with exercising my
curiosity it it's it's a wonderful to
have a chance to begin with questions
but questions working both directions so
for sure and I I have I have I have so
many questions but I'm gonna try to no
I'm gonna try to I'm gonna try to
prioritize them a bit but the the
conceptual vessel term that you used or
Fraser's to say could you give an
example of choosing the right conceptual
vessel yeah so maybe I'll use a couple
but let me start with with one so back
when we were working on the research for
what became good to great a little bit
of a story of what was happening when we
went into the good to great research and
everything we do as a as a research base
to it I had really given the research
team the instruction that I didn't
really want to have a leadership answer
and the reason for that is because I was
always skeptical especially from the
built to last research which had come
before of placing too much emphasis on
having a single leader number one if
you're going to build something truly
enduring it has to transcend the leader
they all go away they all die you can't
have a system based on a single leader
and the second is you can go around in a
big circle where you can say hey if that
company was successful it must have been
a great leader and then if it's not
successful you say they weren't a great
leader after all and you're just in a
big circle you're not learning so I said
to the research team I don't want to
study I don't want to have a leadership
answer and my research team which is
usually composed of some what I would
say highly irreverent smart people who
just work really hard and they love to
challenge me and we had these leads to
what we call it kind of research
symposium because Curious George was our
is our kind of our mask
right of curiosity and we would have
compose iums and and so we would we
would we would be talking about the
research and one day the research team
kind of essentially joined hands when I
came in and they and I said what's up
and they said we're gonna tell you today
that you're wrong I said well what about
and they said well about this anti
leadership bias that you have each of us
were responsible for studying the good
to great journey the inflection of these
companies that were average that that
made that leap in and and we see their
point of inflection the leader have
played a huge role and to ignore that
ignore the evidence you always tell us
Jim pay attention to the evidence we
invoke that here today you're wrong and
and I responded to the team by saying
well when you ask me a question you
remember your high school algebra now of
course dead as I remember if you have
the same variable in the numerator as
the denominator the variable goes away
and so as a relevant differentiator and
so I went to the whiteboard and I put a
little line up there for the numerator
the denominator and I put good two great
companies in the numerator and
comparison companies in the denominator
now our research method and as all gets
to the conceptual vessel but it kind of
have to sort of know how we get there so
all our research is always based on a
method that developed with a great
mentor of mine and one of the themes by
the way I think that's going to come up
in our conversation is what I see is the
treadle role that who luck write the
luck of the right people that intersect
your life plays in the journey and I had
great who luck in a research mentor
named Jerry Porras at Stanford when we
were doing built to last together and
Jerry pushed us to develop this method
where he said look if you study
successful companies or companies that
achieve certain things but you only
study the successes well you're gonna
find they all have buildings well does
that mean having buildings will make you
right as its as my company right and so
he said what we have to
as comparison said and we developed this
as this historical method where you
study the entire history of two evenly
matched companies at the start of the
journey that are the same place same
time same resources same potential and
then one breaks out to a totally
different level than the other and holds
it long enough that you can have
confidence in it and the other that was
a virtually identical twin at that time
does not and at the birth of any
industry for example you have an
explosion of new entrants so all that
early semiconductor companies and in
there you're gonna find a twin pair of
companies that are virtually the same
but one of them becomes Intel and the
other one doesn't
right so why and so I said you always
have to ask what's really different
compared to what it's a it adds huge
amounts to the work just the the
magnitude of work you have to do to do
the comparison because it basically more
than doubles everything you do but
that's how you see and of course you
find all the comparisons also have
buildings so buildings can't be the
answer so I went to the whiteboard and I
said okay so we have good great
companies had these remarkable people
that led them through the transition
well let's look at the comparison
companies and started ticking through
the list and found
oh sure enough the comparison companies
had some remarkable leaders and some of
them or even really extraordinary
leaders I mean Jack Deckard who had
built
Eckerd and Stanley Gault at Rubbermaid I
mean these were really really good
leaders and so I wrote leadership in the
numerator leadership in the denominator
I said guess what the variable drops out
we have it in both it doesn't really
matter as a variable well let's go back
to work and do something useful and and
the team yeah that's the wonderful thing
about smart irreverent young people they
sort of closed ranks on me and they said
you knew you would do that to us so so
we came prepared and and this is when
the team this is the value of having a
great research team saw something that
then led to this notion of the what
eventually became the level 5 idea and
the conceptual vessel for it so
the team said Jim you're right both sets
of companies the good degrades in the
comparisons at the critical moment in
time had leaders and there's no evidence
that the leaders were any less
exceptional in terms of their pure
leadership ability but there's something
different about the good of great
leaders they're cut from a different
cloth it's not about their personality
many of them were shy and reserved and
soft spoke and never drew attention to
themselves right so it wasn't about that
there's something different about them
and that became interesting and
essentially what happened then was the
question was what's the difference
between these leaders it wasn't
leadership because they were both
leaders who did leadership there was
something different about the leaders
and so there was the signature of their
humility and then their fierce will on
behalf of something that's not about
them they were able to subsume their ego
into the company and that blend of
humility and will is what stood out and
that was different from the comparisons
so that was interesting so you kind of
step back and you say okay now how do we
capture that conceptually and I went out
onto my porch and I started thinking
okay is this just an idea they're just
humble leaders no that's not quite it
there's something about this duality is
it a dialectic didn't seem to be quite
right and I started playing around with
different things and I I had this flash
that went through my mind of it's a
hierarchy and it's a pyramid of
capabilities and you kind of climb up
this hierarchy it was sort of almost
like a Maslow's hierarchy except it was
of leadership and that there was there
were levels to it and I thought this is
a hierarchy of levels level 1 would be
individual capabilities and so that
would be at the base of the pyramid and
then you go from individual capabilities
to level 2 which is you get really good
at playing well with others right good
team skills and then level 3 you would
learn how to manage and by the way as an
aside never denigrate great management
anybody who's had a poor manager knows
how awful that is to work for one and
how great it is to work for a great
manager and then above level three
becomes level four and you go from be
managing to learning to lead and then
there was a higher level and that higher
level was the level five and the level
five well you you could be a leader as a
level four to be a level five leader you
had to go to the next level of the
hierarchy and add in this ambition for
something's bigger than yourself with
humility and with well and that when you
stand back and you looked at that you
could look at it and say the right way
to convey this idea is as a hierarchy
that you grow through as distinct from
some other way I had to kind of find the
the way of capturing and then the
critical thing is it's not leading it's
are you a 5 or a 4 and here's sort of
the overall pyramid and just to
illustrate let me just invoke somebody
who wrote their Princeton thesis on what
became a level 5 journey one of the
great leaders that I've gotten to know
is Wendy Kopp the founder of sure's for
America right America yeah she wrote her
senior thesis on it which is why I'm
always curious I'm at Jack Bogle wrote
his senior thesis on mutual funds and
ended up creating an amazing thing
Wendy Kopp wrote wrote hers on on what
became Teach for America but if you look
at Wendy Kopp if you were to ask the
question you know where is she on that
well she goes she went through all all
the levels and but she's not just a
leader she has that extra dimension
where she's got that genuine personal
humility and an absolutely ferocious
resolve for the overall cause that is
not about her and if anybody that's met
Wendy or seen her you would never think
this is about Wendy Kopp you would never
think but if you ever doubted her
resolve right you know there's that
image of her sitting there trying to get
her first funding for Teach for America
where her images I put glue stick on the
bottom of my pants and I would not leave
the chair until I got a $25,000 check I
mean just sheer will and will for
ultimately
the kids and what how the kids lives
could be changed and yet genuine
humility and so she went to the top of
the hierarchy and so when I stand back I
look at it and say that's the right
conceptual vessel for this journey of
what we had seen
now other other concepts may I jump in
one second sure please the question was
genuine humility how do you identify
genuine humility what are the
characteristics and had you separated
from false humility or what someone
presents as humility I guess I'm
wondering how you how you how how we
imputed that from the research day
correct yeah yeah it's a great question
so so first of all in all of our work we
start not surprisingly with a question
of curiosity right it always has to be
something I just am really curious
enough to go through the years of
suffering to get some insights and they
need to translate that into the research
method the comparison method the
historical method and so forth and then
you collect vast amounts of information
so in the good degree and and and the
key is you're not looking for anything
in particular you're looking for
patterns of difference why did one set
of companies what was different about
them versus the others as you walk
through time and oh and or what kinds of
decisions they made and so forth always
going to that difference question and
and so what we began to notice is that
the the good great leaders was
fascinating that number one you can you
can do what's called a vent analysis so
you can do something like say let's call
an event the number of times and
speeches you use the vertical pronoun
versus you don't over the course of a
career and that's something you can
count right so you can look at it and
say let's take the good two great CEOs
and let's take the comparison CEOs and
look at every letter they wrote that you
can get hold on let's look at every
speech they ever gave every interview
they
gave right when you got mountains and
mountains of information now let's go
through and literally count how many
times they tend to take credit
themselves how many times they give the
credit to others how many times they
don't use the vertical pronoun I how
many times they they do now later of
course it's so many red level-5 they
could try to pretend to be level 5 I'll
never forget an email when somebody
sending me an email it says help and I
opened it up and says dear Jim our CEO
just walked in and announced he's level
5 what do we do have it reread the
chapter so people don't do what they
were doing I know they weren't trying to
show themselves one way or another
that's the thing about looking over
course in entire history or career you
can count things
how many times did they allow themselves
to be on the cover of the magazine how
many times when when when they're in
discussions about things that did not go
well right you can look at window and
mirror events things that did not go
well well one approach is when something
does not go well you can point out the
window and subtly or not so subtly
attribute the reason it didn't go well
the factors outside yourself right the
economy or somebody let you down or
partner didn't come through or whatever
it happens to be but somehow it's not
you or there's the window approach which
is your kind of natural tendency is all
that might be true it doesn't change the
fact that I'm responsible and I'm own
this and this is the mistake I made and
so on and so forth and you can look and
again it's comparative what did the
comparison CEOs do you can count a lot
of events of some version of pointing
out the window
what did the good to great CEOs do you
can count a lot of versions of pointing
in the mirror and so you begin to add
all this up right and over the course of
decades because we look sometimes over
50 60 years and in some CEOs were in
harness for multiple decades
that then and and since they're all
publicly traded companies people often
ask well why do you only study publicly
traded companies my answer is because
that's where the data is right it's not
because right because that's that's the
beauty they all have to report the same
way they all have annual reports they
all have earnings calls they all have
all these things over time that you can
then use as data sets I've never I'm not
really a business author I just happen
to have used companies as the method to
study human systems because there's
great data and and so that's where the
data is and if you do that and we have
6,000 years at the combined corporate
history and the research database pretty
soon you can start counting a lot of
things and then you can begin to say
there's a substantial amount of
quantitative evidence that adds up to a
greater level of humility in these than
those and that's how you get there may I
ask you a question about counting yeah
all right so I we have a number of books
we could talk about and we are going to
talk about some of them but built to
last has a subtitle successful habits of
visionary companies yeah I'm very
fascinated by what might be the
successful habits of Jim Collins and
this is a question about accounting by
the course of doing some of the homework
for this conversation I have come across
different ways that you seem to measure
your time and your days and I'd love to
explore that for just a little bit sure
so the first was I read that you had and
this may have evolved or changed by this
point but a stopwatch with three timers
in your pocket McCann you and that it
was an instead of indicative of creative
teaching and other yeah but could could
you explain that habit please for people
who are familiar well so actually let me
tell you the story of how it began yes
what's it three were about and then how
its evolved into something a little
simpler and a little more powerful and
what I do with it every single day okay
so I I don't want to pretend that I'm
normal okay so what I would describe
it's not normal behavior but this is
this is it so when I when I was 36 years
old I made the decision and we can come
- this later if you want to talk about
big bets and doing scary things such as
betting our career betting our lives
Joanne and I on an entrepreneurial path
let me just kind of step back and sort
of share the origins of this yeah so I
was teaching at Stanford and I it was a
marvelous journey and of course that
great mentors and learned how to do my
research there that's where Jerry and I
did built to last but I had a another
mentor who encouraged me to think about
whether I wanted to do a self directed
path or not I used to say to my students
because I taught entrepreneurship and
small business I I always said to my
students why don't you go do something
on your own
I mean why give over all your creative
energies for somebody else's thing I
would at least challenge them to think
about that and I would say if you're
really interested in business you don't
have to go to work for IBM to be in
business you can do your own so my
students this is the wonderful thing
about great students they hold you to
account right they said well right what
are you doing that's entrepreneurial
this doesn't look like a very
entrepreneurial thing teaching these
classes and being here and I like
betting on myself so I had this idea you
don't have to be at IBM to be in
business why do I have to be at a
university to be a professor
so I said to Joann I said you know I
think I have this idea of I'd like to be
a self-employed professor to endow my
own chair and to grant my own opinion so
Joanne who we've done these things
together through life she went along
with idea the idea was to try to pursue
really big questions that wouldn't be
constrained by things you could do in
only a year and the first big bet on
that was the research and built to last
and it was coming out and I said let's
just bet everything let's let's go and
so we launched this huge bet that
everything on that book didn't know if
it would work we were down to on less
than $10,000 we were actually really
scared we call it our Thelma Louise
moment we were we were we were like
watching off the cliff together simply
wanted to get to the other side
and but it was a huge it was a huge bet
and we didn't know if it would work but
I was very clear about one thing I did
not want to have a half-life of quality
in the work and it's one of the
wonderful things about working a built
to last with Jerry back at Stanford
no one knew who I was no one called no
one paid any attention so for six years
of working on that research project I
could just go into the cave and work and
work and work and that kind of deep work
I mean you have to go deep into the data
deep into the research deep into the
thinking the long cycles of reflection
that's how you get the ideas and that's
how you do good stuff and what I was
worried that what would happen is if I
went from being invisible to being
visible and that if I was fortunate
enough to have a success then I might
wake up in five or six or seven years
and have not gone back to the wellspring
of the deep quiet solitude of work and
and then your second book is half as
good right and then the next book after
that is only half as good again I wanted
the quality to always get better and so
I thought well you know what's
interesting is a professor or a
university is a place that really
encourages that because it's sort of
designed to allow you to spend your life
in that tranquility and so I went to
some thousand eleven come on great and
in effect and I said how do the people
in the Academy that you most respect in
yourself spend their time and I got a
consistent answer 50 30 2050 of your
time in new intellectual creative work
30 percent of your time in teaching and
20 percent of your time and other stuff
that just has to get done serving on
committees you know whatever it happens
to be that you have to do and so I
thought that sounds good I'm just going
to start doing that so
started as I was heading out on the the
Thelma Louise Lea counting my hours
every day and I would count how many
hours in the day were creative new
intellectual and that the goal was that
had to be above 50% then how many hours
would be in teaching and how many hours
would be in other stuff like I mean I
had somebody gotta balance the
QuickBooks right and so I started
counting and that's where the triple
stopwatch came I found this wonderful
stripper triple stopwatch where I could
constantly go back and forth and at the
end of the day I would have the tonal
later I came to the realization that
what really mattered was the first
bucket the creative work and so I
eventually simplified it there's a
concept and great by choice called the
20-mile March and so I I kind of had a
20-mile March I just didn't know that
that concept yet and the idea being
something you just do really
consistently over time that imposes a
very high level of discipline that
accumulates to results and so I
simplified it and I just simply said can
I just simply count the number of
creative hours I'm gonna turn and then
hold myself to an account so at the end
of every single day I open a spreadsheet
and that spreadsheet has three cells on
a line and that's for the day the first
thing is just a simple accounting of
what happened that day you know where
did my time go what did I do
what etcetera can you give it sorry to
interrupt but I would love this is the
stuff I love the what might a
description for the day look like is it
three sentences four sentences what what
might it depends I mean actually the
very best days don't have much in it at
all they are got up early two hours of
really great creative work breakfast
with Joanne five hours creative work
workout nap three hours of creative work
enjoyed dinner with Joanne bed I mean
that's like a great day
but other days are full of lots of other
choppy things and so what I tend to do
is to try to capture a bit of what
happened with sleep what happened with
the the main tasks of the day if there
were some really interesting
conversations that happened or something
that hidden those all note those they're
markers so that I can always go back and
show with you how I use that was in a
minute because I actually do these
correlations with all of that and then
the second cell is the number of
creative hours I got that day now
there's no rule about how many you get
in a day sometimes there's zero and
sometimes they they can be nine or ten
which would be a huge number and but
then it calculates over the last and the
end of March which I don't think I've
missed for well over thirty years and I
hope to hit four for a lot longer now is
every single 365 day cycle every single
one every single day well if you
calculate back the last 365 days the
total number of creative hours must
exceed 1,000 no matter what it doesn't
matter if you're sick it doesn't matter
if if there's other stuff you'd like a
thousand creative hours a year as a
minimum baseline they can be above that
that's fine but never once there can't
be a single day in any 365 day cycle
January 2 to January to July 22 to July
22 September 9 to September 9 doesn't
matter always has to be above the
thousand creative hours and you watch it
and I put it on the whiteboard here at
the lab the three-month pace so you take
the last three months multiply times for
the six month pace and then the current
365 and that is a way to kind of monitor
if I start seeing that those numbers
start to go down you know I'll change my
behavior and sometimes I have a big
buffer and sometimes I don't and the
idea is if you stay with that eventually
you're going to have work now there's a
third cell
that I put in there that most people
don't know as much about because people
know about the hours think somewhat but
I am all of us have what I you know dark
times difficult times all of us have
good times right but here's an
interesting thing I noticed which is
that if you're kind of going through a
funk it colors your whole life and you
tend to think your whole life is a funk
because you're looking through that lens
and so I thought well you know but
actually I feel like my life is really
pretty good but when you're in that
other place it's not it doesn't feel
that way right
and so what I started to do is I started
creating a code which is + 2 + 1 0 minus
1 minus 2 and the other thing I put in
and in the key on all this by the ways
you have to do it every day in real time
you can't like five days later look back
and say how did I feel that day and that
what this is a totally subjective how
quality was the day what was it what a
plus 2 was a super positive day
this is emotionally speaking exactly
just just like was it a great day a plus
2 is a just a great day doesn't mean it
wasn't there might not have been a
really difficult day might have been a
day of a really hard rock climb it might
have been a day of really hard writing
but it felt really good
right it might have been a day of an
intense conversation but really
meaningful that friend or something
right but it but it adds up to is a plus
2 plus 1 is another positive day zero is
yeah you know - one's kind of a net
tonne negative and -2 is those are bad
days all right and he put it in before
you go to bed because if you try to
remember if I were to ask you Tim right
now 17 days ago or even five days ago to
give the score you're going to be
distorted by how you're feeling today oh
for sure
Abby right yeah I mean memory is the
u.s. people what they ate two days ago
they're gonna get off by 40% 50%
calories for sure yeah so I know I start
to have I got the creative hours March
which is it's kind of discipline and
service of creativity and and I and it's
relentless right it just stays with me
constantly it
you never get a break from it you can
take breaks but you can never get a
break from the thousand floor but that
other has proved to be incredibly useful
for me because now what you can do is
sort the spreadsheet and you can say
over the last five years what's going on
in all the positive oh and over the last
five that's where the descriptions come
in yeah exactly
and over the last five years what's
going on in the minus two days and now
as I navigate is kind of like the
simplex method in operations research
where you find optimal by never really
knowing that optimal is ahead of time
you do it by a series of iterative steps
of the next step hold on can you explain
that I'm from Long Island too sometimes
it takes me a minute could you can you
explain what that was one more time yeah
sure so what my undergraduate was a
thing called mathematical sciences with
a heavy dose of philosophy and math
sciences was pure mathematics computer
science statistics and operations
research and in operations research
there's a method developed by a guy
named George Danzig called the simplex
method and essentially the idea is that
if you're really trying to find the
optimal answer to a multivariate problem
where there's lots and lots of variables
even the biggest computers couldn't
basically do a giant spreadsheet and
sort there's just too many permutations
and what he showed was under certain
conditions
all you have to do is find the local
optimum like what's the best next step
right and then you to reset and then
what's the next best step and that he
showed that under certain conditions
that is mathematically guaranteed to
navigate you to the optimal end point
and that was the simplex method as I
understand him it was 30 40 years ago
when I was in the class but so I've
always had that idea in mind so you kind
of navigate step by step and so I think
about it as in navigating life I want
more of the things that create the plus
twos and less of the things that create
the minus twos but the difference that's
helped me is I know what they are yeah
and and I can start you know it's not
that life is
perfectly you can do a simple more of
this less of that then more of this less
of that that makes any sense it makes
perfect sense what are some of the the
patterns that you found for for either
the doom or column or the dual s column
for yourself yeah so so when I look at
those patterns I would say on the plus
twos there are almost two contradictory
components and that contradictory but
they're just really different flavors
one is the solitude of really hard work
and sometimes what one of my favorite
days will be I get up I never leave the
house and I basically get to just lose
myself in the research or in the writing
or in the making sense of things it's a
very incredible simplicity of the day as
I as I as I m61 now and I think about
what comes next and I intend to keep
creating I want to stay in some version
of that March for a really long time my
role models have all done that but I
think about life as having three three
things at least I think are really
important one of them is increasing
simplicity just sheer simplicity to is
time and flow state and flow States not
easy and the third is time with people I
love and and and so when I look at the
at those plus twos they have a lot of
that a lot of the days would be days of
high simplicity not much happen there
were very few moving parts about a lot
of deep hard work and flow state I might
have been writing or doing a concept or
creating something or I mean just you're
lost in the work or rock-climbing
problem or rock climbing exactly exactly
it's arduous but you're lost in it those
are great the other though for me is the
time with people I love and the other
dimension while I wouldn't describe
myself as a highly
social type person I love the solitude
of the hard work the other side is there
the people in my life and there are many
I have great friends really great great
friends that many decades friends
friends back to third grade seventh
grade all my college roommates I mean my
personal Bandra brothers I mean I have
friends and and and my wife
we've married 38 years I got 40 engaged
4 days after our first date
4 days after your first date yes that's
true yeah
ok we might come back to that we might
the thing is when you have those days
where you're really present and engaged
with people you really love those are
plus 2 days they may not have
accomplished anything or in the case of
climbing it might be that I went out
climbing with one of my best friends and
I don't even necessarily remember the
climb it was with a friend and so my
plus two days are either very solitude
or very connected but connected to
people that have these long and during
really really wonderful relationships in
life and those make plus twos I love it
you you at some point in life need to
meet my friend Josh Waitzkin who you and
he have very similar heuristics he was
the basis for the book and the movie
searching for bobby fisher' so his first
life was in chess but I won't
I won't take us too far off track but at
some point I think you guys would really
really get along ok let me dive into a
couple of clarifications if I may
because this is this is this is so juicy
I can't I can't I don't want to just
move on to the next thing you can have
all these people now creating
spreadsheets I was gonna say if this
writing thing doesn't work out for you
you should create you have you have a
spreadsheet company you have a
journaling company available to you
creative so this is a word that means
different things to different people
what are the main activities or what are
some of the activities that are square
in the creative bucket for you and the
reason I'm asking is I'm thinking of how
I spend my own time and and you have a
team I've I suspect a much smaller team
but for instance if you are working on a
book that requires interviews would
spending time scheduling those
interviews count is creative or what's
or is there a cut-off even if it's in
service of a larger creative project we
have admin and then you have creative so
for you what counts towards the hours
marked creative so so you've hit upon
exactly where the gray zone is on this
and in general in order to again I have
to go back to what's the overall
objective the overall objective is that
over time there's quality work and so I
can't start calling things creative that
in the end wouldn't lead to some kind of
creative output and by the way sometimes
I creative output ends up in a drawer
because it just doesn't make it to the
world but you have to just keep working
and I think it was like being an artist
in a studio and so well are getting the
paintbrushes ready to paint part of the
creative I would say yes I would say
that organizing the tools and and and
maybe even ordering paint right because
it's in direct service to the creation
of what I ultimately might be in a
canvas whether the world sees it or not
I define creative as any activity that
has a reasonably direct link to the
creation of something that is new and
potentially replicable or durable I like
that yeah please expand on that so so
for example if if we have in this
conversation right I mean there's
already elements that will count as
somewhat creative because just even you
start thinking about if an idea pops
into my head and then that leads to
supporting some other you know concept
or piece of work that I'm working
because a lot of times I'm sure you find
this too
is there's a seed of an insight that's
lurking in the back of your brain and
then in the process of conversation or
in the process of trying to articulate
something or in some other mechanism it
gets jarred out of your brain and then
all of a sudden you see it bounce on the
table and then you go I need to put that
in a bag and not forget it right and
right and so and sometimes that happens
I'll give you an example of how
something that that that can turns out
to be a kind of a creative moment I
wasn't anticipating as a creative moment
I was meeting with a no I can't say who
it is but it was a very towering super
charismatic super genius founder who is
you know sort of to his world the way
say Walt Disney might have been to his
world I mean just you know truly a a
once in a generation
but unlike Disney this person never
really started thinking about the
systems that would allow him to build a
company that could really ultimately go
beyond beyond him and there were
challenges with that and so we're
talking us trying to figure out how do i
how do I get through to this and there
were there are other people on the team
who didn't really want to step up into
certain roles and a whole bunch of other
stuff and so they could kind of picture
that as I'm challenging I'm trying to
teach them set the stage for making a
built to last company and and as they
give you that as well what's creative in
that you're just kind of wrestling with
this with these people and all of a
sudden in the middle of the conversation
I remember I just I just turned and I
looked at him I said here's the problem
you sir are a genius so let's just start
there's the problem and and what you
have is a thousand helpers now so long
as your stoma genius and so long as all
these helpers want to help you being a
genius with a thousand helpers that's
gonna work really well until either a
some day you're not a genius or B you're
gone in which case this company just
hollows out there's nothing left there
is no company all this is is a genius
with a thousand helper
and as sort of a vessel called a company
it's nothing more well right then that
was when this thing came out of my head
bounced on the table I had never used
that phrase before and I immediately I
made a note on my notepad and I went
back and if you look at me the great
there's a section when I'm trying to
describe the comparison CEOs in contrast
to the good to great CEOs where I talk
about the genius with a thousand helpers
and I contrast how the level 5 leaders
come out it is that's the last thing
they'd want to be right and how they'd
want to build a culture and a company
and ultimately be the architect of a
great system versus being the genius
with a thousand helpers and there's a
flowchart in there that sort of
describes a different center that came
out of that conversation so I got to
count that conversation as creative even
though when I went into it I didn't know
that that would happen so I wouldn't
have counted it normally there's other
times where shiraz doing some research
on k-12 education recently and the
process of really deciding who I wanted
to interview that would count that's
like assembling the paintbrushes if I'm
balancing the QuickBooks account because
I have to do that and you know or I'm um
I don't know
there are things we'll just sort of
clearly fall outside of it and I don't
count it I try to be a hard counter so
that I stay on the March this is super
helpful and it also made me think about
how if someone were to and I was
thinking about this earlier as well how
the 50% creative 30% teaching 20% other
in in in some respects have a well we
will get to this maybe it's no I wasn't
gonna say maybe it's maybe it's not if
fly will exactly but the yeah but the
the creativity can lead into teaching
the teaching then can lead back into the
creativity because it forces you in some
respects or at least catalyzes you to
express things in ways that you might
not
otherwise and also points out things
that are unclear Lee formed if you then
try to convey them to somebody else and
in fact it's interesting and preparing
for today and I I love to prepare for a
conversation by thanking food what we
might chat about but then it's not a
script it's like it's like a it's like
having a you know different plays you
can have in a football game like what
might happen in the game and then that's
a conversation even what if I get
together with a girl a good friend I
usually will write down three things I'd
love to chat about today we may or may
not get to them but one of the things I
did for today was I thought I wonder if
Tim will ask me what's my own flywheel
and and so I actually took a content
writing it down if we come back to that
later I'd be happy to yeah we will we
will absolutely come back to that and I
I have a path there yeah so you
mentioned a while back actually before I
just have to check this box or it's
gonna bug me yeah sleep tracking see
many doesn't sleep how do you note or
modify or have you modified your sleep
can you talk to us about I think most
people would agree it's important but
how have you monitored and and modified
your sleep well again I'm not normal
okay that's precisely why I'm asking no
but I but one of the things that struck
me a number of years ago is that we
spend so much time thinking about time
management and I'm not really it I mean
even though I described this county and
so if I'm not really a time management
sort of person I'm a like I don't I
don't have kind of I have to organize my
time a certain way or whatever that
thousand creative hours as long as I
stay there there are some millions of
ways I can get there right so I'm it's
like it's like a constraint within which
now I can have a ton of freedom right so
I'm not overly regimented I'm just
disciplined and there's a big difference
and I until when I was I was thinking
well wait a minute if a third of our
lives approximately were spent related
why don't we put as much thought into
time management of sleep as we do into
the rest of our day
maybe it's just ignoring the huge piece
of it so one of the things I did was
without to my knowledge having a sleep
issue I and I find my insurance wouldn't
pay for this or anything I just was
curious there's a sleep center and I
think it's the National Jewish Hospital
here in in Denver they have a sleep lab
where they'll do sleep tests and stuff
and I just said hey can I come and get
sleep tested and so I went down there
and just scheduled myself in and spent
the night and had them put the
electrodes on and I kind of feel like
I'm my own wrap in life my own lab rat
while I'm always studying myself somehow
right and and this is a have a little
book called the bug book where I'm the
bug and I'm studying the bug called Jim
that's how I figured out where I was
gonna go in life and so anyway so I went
down to the Sleep Lab and and I said I'm
gonna study to study sleep is too strong
of a word I'm gonna be a student of the
science of sleep and so because it's a
third of my life I why don't they
understand it so I I got the sleep test
and I found out I didn't have any you
know serious to sleep pathologies I
learned about the different aspects of
sleep and what the big takeaway I got
about sleep well as we tend to think of
this idea of you know 7 hours a day or
80 hours a day and what I learned from
this little journey and I'm again I want
to underscore it's not like I were a
sleep expert or anything or I'm just
trying to figure it out for myself
is it's actually the number of hours
that you get over say a 10 day cycle so
if you go up and you do a big climb like
when Tommy and I did our climb and El
Cap together and do it in a day
that means 24 hours you're gonna be
awake for 36 hours ok so if you're
basically like oh I couldn't do it
without sleep well you're never gonna do
it you could perform it really high
levels with zero sleep over a day you
wouldn't want to do it over 10 days
though and so the the what I started
thinking was what really matters is the
amount of quality sleep I get over say a
10 day cycles so early on after all this
I actually started counting and I would
count naps and I would count to just try
to keep again very much like 220 mile
of the creative hours as long as I was
staying above 70 over a 10 day cycle
however I got there that was fine I've
since found that what really I I
probably still hit that number but
having counted it for about a decade
meant that I ingrained the patterns of
how to come at it and what I've learned
is I guess three two or three things
specifically about about the sleep
process for me this is just personal one
the 20-minute rule if you wake up in the
middle of the night and you check the
time first of all it's also by the way
fun to see if you can guess what time it
is right but then check the time and
then and then if you're not back to
sleep in 20 minutes get up and go and
then I love it all sometimes go lose
myself and again back to the simple work
whatever there's something really
quieted get up at 3:00 or 4:00 in the
morning and just you're just there with
the creative stuff you're doing that's a
great time sometimes you wake up at 3:00
sometimes you wake up at 7:00 the second
is for me I'm really really lucky I have
the genetic ability to nap in any
situation I took a nap I woke up eight
minutes before our conversation today
I'm serious yeah I know you are yeah and
and I and so for me my my little secret
extra capability that I just was born
with was I can nap pretty much anywhere
under any conditions and I can dream you
give me 12 minutes I'll dream if you
give me fifty five minutes I'll dream
and I can wake up and boom be fine it's
just genetic but naps are my sort of
saving like they give me this sense of
like oh whatever happens I'll be fine
because I can always close my eyes when
I can nap sitting up when when do you
choose to know why I have two favorite
times of napping three favorite times in
epic one is airplanes are great for
napping so you never I never eat
anything on a plane or you know do any
of that I'm either tried to do something
creative or
sleep and I have I really have a
sleeping kit which includes --is bose
noise-canceling headphones and eye
covers and a doughnut pillow that the
headphone can go in so that it's
actually like really like kind of
creating a micro environment so you can
sleep on an airplane or wherever you
happen to be the second place if I'm not
traveling which I try not to do too much
anymore afternoons are great for a nap
because you have a really good morning
and then you just and then you get us
that wonderful afternoon glow of
creative time sometimes if you took a
nap from say 2 to 3 or 3 to 4 and then
you have that marvelous like 4 to 7 in
the evening and it somehow coincides
with the end of the day that can be an
it's like a second warning am i but my
favorite absolute sleeping pattern is oh
so when Joanne's doing runner for bike
rides across the country and she's gone
for six or seven weeks doing it I'll
fall into a pattern worm a lot of days
I'll go to bed at 11:00 and get up at
3:00 I'll roll out of bed and then I'll
I'll do the creative work stuff usually
creative or preparing teaching from say
three till seven you don't eat anything
you don't drink anything you don't have
a cup of coffee just go roll right in
and then you go back to sleep from 7:00
or 8:00 until 10:00 or 11:00 and if
you've ever been under general
anesthetic that second sleep is like
generally Recep I mean you blink and it
and it's just that that deep dark bang
and all of a sudden three hours are gone
and then I get a second morning because
mornings are the best I get a second
morning when I get up and then you have
breakfast and then you get this really
great energetic day that for me is a
perfect sleep day Wow I I have these
things I'm dying to get to but then you
keep bringing up interesting things
which I know no I squarely blame you for
that but I'm glad you're doing it the
bug book yes you mentioned it in passing
what yeah what is the buck book could
you please elaborate on the bug book on
the bug book so when
I think a lot of us and I certainly was
one of them have a kind of the we
struggle in our 20s to get clarity about
how to deploy ourselves in the world and
because everything up until you kind of
finish you know high school or college
or graduate school but it was kind of
structured you don't really have to
think about it it's like oh I got a I
got to figure out how to do these math
problems or whatever and but life isn't
really like that and then all of a
sudden hit hit life and life is much
more ambiguous and so you're trying to
navigate through it so III like a lot of
people was was I'm trying to figure out
how best to deploy myself in my 20s and
I had multiple things that help me do
that but one of them let me just
introduce a concept okay and then I'll
tie it into the bug book because is how
I challenged young people to think about
it there's a concept and good to great
called the Hedgehog concept and the idea
of the Hedgehog concept is is to sort of
simplify down we found it by studying
companies we found that when they really
focus on one or a few really big things
and made very disciplined decisions over
time those would accumulate and begin to
build some real results and eventually
what would become the flywheel effect
which we'll chat about a little bit
later and the Hedgehog concept is the
intersection of three circles so for a
company it's doing what you're deeply
passionate about because if you're not
passionate about it you can't endure
long enough to really really do
something exceptional to it it's make
the second circle is what you can be the
best in the world app and if you can't
be the best in the world at it leave it
to others so for example it doesn't mean
being big right you could have a truly
great local restaurant it's never going
to be big but it's the absolute best in
the world at a particular thing that it
does in its specific community right
that and no large company could come in
and be better than them at that right
that's very Hedgehog even though it's
not big and then the third is that you
have an economic engine and you know how
it works and so if you have the interest
section of those three are energy it's
going to go into things that we're
passionate about and we can be the best
of the world that and the driver
economic engine you're in your hedgehog
now there's a personal analogy to the
Hedgehog and this gets back to the bug
book I am NOT a big believer in sort of
thinking of traditional careers I'm a
big believer in thinking of finding your
Hedgehog and then really building
flywheel momentum with that over time
and so as that the personal version of
the Hedgehog is again doing circle one
what you're passionate about and love to
do the kinds of stuff that when you do
what you say I sure hope I get a long
way because I love being the second
circle isn't best in the world because
if you said well if I can't be the best
orthopedic surgeon I won't do it well
then we'd only have one right that's not
good right so so so it's what you aren't
encoded for and what you are encoded for
is different than what you're good at so
what I went to college I thought I was
going to be a mathematician because I
was one of those kids that was good at
math and that's why I majored in math
sciences but then I met at Stanford the
people who are genetically encoded for
math there were not me I was good at
math they were encoded for math it's
like being an athlete where you thought
you were a good athlete till you met the
incredible natural gifted athlete you
realize I could never see to spin to the
basket like he did or I could never see
to put the ball there running down the
field playing soccer the way she did I
just wouldn't have seen it it was a gift
that's the encoding and so you have to
find what you're encoded for as distinct
from just what you're good at and then
the third is you have an economic engine
and you can there and you can fund your
goals your objectives of things you're
trying to get done when you have all
three of those I'm passionate about it
I'm encoded for it and I have an
economic engine in it now you're in your
hedgehog now when you're you're 20
there's all these sort of
paint-by-numbers kids approach to life
right you can be a professor you can be
a businessman you can be a lawyer you
can be whatever right and the nice thing
about a paint-by-numbers kid is you
actually don't have to think about it
that much because as long as you stay in
the lines and you in your paint you're
gonna end up with a nice picture at the
end but the only way to paint a
masterpiece is to start with a blank
canvas and and that is sort of figuring
out those three circles and then making
your own unique series of decisions
consistent with the Hedgehog of those
three circles and they may or may not
fall into a traditional bucket and so I
was trying to find my way and I started
this little book and it was inspired by
a mentor named Rachelle miners who
suggested that what I do is I study
myself like a bug and imagine with
dispassionate objectivity as you're
going through life your little notes
where you're observing the bug called
Jim but very scientifically clinically
and so I remember I was I was working at
HP for a couple years out of graduate
school great great company at the time
for sure but I wasn't really constructed
to be in a large company but I was
trying to navigate my way and one day I
had to give a presentation on how
networked computers work and this was
back in the 1980s when it was early on
in that and I had to figure out how to
communicate to everyone really the
essence in our and our team of how
network computing was going to work and
how it fit together and I had to sort of
conceptualize it and then I had to teach
it and and share with all of a sudden I
had this day where it's like wow that
was really fun to figure it out to
figure out how to conceptualize it to
figure out how to put it in concepts
everybody could understand to share it
with everyone to teach me my bug book
when I'm then writing the bug Jim really
loves making sense of something
difficult breaking it down into
understandable pieces and teaching it to
others it was an observation in the
journal the other thing is might be
something like the bug
Jim we had really languish if he had to
spend a lot of time in senseless
meetings this is not good right and so I
would and constantly observing and then
eventually that allowed me to that was
that sort of observation clinical then
allowed me to eventually sort of head
back to teaching at Stanford when I was
thirty which then became really the
start of the the real journey of what
happened with the book book did you
write things in the bug book each
evening did you do it to keep it in your
back pocket and when there was a out
like an outlying impactful or
emotionally notable event you'd write in
it what was the strike how you used it
if there wasn't he at that time I'm more
now just kind of in the coding we
described earlier because I'm I'm one of
those really lucky people that I found
this earth stuff early I remember the
moment I hit the classroom at Stanford
first teaching the small business and
entrepreneurship class I just knew I'm
home I'm in the three circles like this
is I know what's going to guide in some
version some permutation of this
probably for the rest of my life and I
just knew it but until then I had to
kind of get to where I could see that
and so for those years I would say if I
bet if I went back and looked at them
and I haven't done that they're in my
basement I'll bet you that probably five
out of seven days
there's reasonably thorough entries in
there and and and those entries would
also be things like noting sort of
projecting out and a lot of it was often
what I would describe is pattern
recognition where you'd know be noting
things but I would also always be
scanning for people that I could see
them older people much older than me and
I could and and the question is I could
somehow picture that some version of
what they do somehow resonated and I
would note that what was it about it
that resonated why did I look up to that
person
I'd spend a lot of it not just on my own
experiences but also very much on people
that I admired very not people from afar
people I knew and observed now for their
achievements but something about the
quality of what they were and that was
of also a big part of that that
observation process okay this is the
perfect layup segue so thank you for
what you just said to a follow-on to you
mentioning that you're 61 years old yeah
and I read in a piece and the Irish
times you can feel free to fact-check
this but you you were quoted as saying
you know the big years are 60 to 90 to
me I wanted Worf what happened before
this with what comes next and in between
that quote was broken up into two pieces
it says he adds pointing out that when
he first met Peter Drucker then aged 86
the Vienna born sage still had 10 books
left in him so but McPhee is to you in a
way wanting to know what it was like to
study under him Peter Drucker is to me
so I have a copy of the effective
executive of reddit's more times than I
can count
I'm fascinated by this man but have
never actually spoken to anyone who has
spent any time with them can you would
you mind just explaining who who he is
for people who don't know and then just
talking about your your history with
Drucker hmm
well first of all in the effective
executive I was a very honored to have
the opportunity to write the foreword to
the 50th anniversary edition Oh No
kidding
yep yep and I'd you might want to look
it up because I stood back and I said I
essentially said I'm gonna distill you
know 10 things I learned from Peter
Drucker in that forward some of which
tie into the effect of executive but
some were sort of broader than that
and it was very interesting to sit down
and sort of think about some of those
some of those things I learned from
Peter so just sort of intersect a little
bit with with Peter and and Peter was
boy
so let's talk about who luck okay
to that I have been so who lucky and and
it didn't start that way because I
didn't really have a great relationship
with my dad and then and I and he died
young and you know and so I kind of
decided I would sort of create my own
father by reading biographies and and
and people that I would look up to and I
formed a personal board of directors
came up with that idea in the 1980s and
started putting people on it and so I
went up and they were often people who I
just admired for their character right
more than their accomplishments and and
I would let them kind of kind of shape
me I'd hope a little bit later we might
an opportunist talk about one really
amazing person in that fellow named Bill
is here one of my my mentors I learned
from but Peter was a person who I just
if somebody said to me well somebody did
say to me so a fellow named Tom Brown
from industry week magazine way way back
when but I don't even think we'd publish
built to last yet we did an interview
with me and Jerry at Stanford and and he
said well who who's most of a role model
for you that you was looked up to and I
said Peter Drucker
I said why I said well because he really
asked big questions and and so Tom
unbeknownst to me I had previously
interviewed Peter for something and he
calls up Peter and he says there's this
guy he's maybe it's gonna take his own
path he really admires you he's 35 years
old he's up there teaching at Stanford
would you be willing to to spend some
time with him
so out of the blue I get this voicemail
haha I cannot wait mail and I III
hesitate to try to mimic the Austrian
accent because it just sound terrible
but it's something along the lines of
this is Peter Drucker right it's coming
through my voice mail and and he says
would you please give me a call I would
love for you to meet with me okay
so he is almost exactly 50 years older
than me at this point I'm heading
thirty-six he's he's headin to 86 and I
I call him back from the Seattle Airport
and and I call him up and and I said mr.
Drucker the this Jim Collins and and he
yells into the phone speak up I'm not
young anymore and so we arranged this
day and I think it was December 10 1994
if I recall correctly and I get on a
plane and I go down to Claremont and by
the way this is just as let me just
pause here for something for anybody you
know you anyone that's listening if
somebody is willing to give you mentor
time like that you owe you owe it to
them and to you to go prepared and then
to do a lot of writing after so I put an
entire couple three days into preparing
for being able to meet with Peter and
then when I came home I saw I still
probably have I'm sure my notes I mean i
sat down and just and I just processed
and wrote and wrote and wrote everything
i gleaned from that meeting and there
were others
you know interactions later but but that
meeting and that that notion of you you
owe them the respect of going prepare to
sound like hey I want to hang out let's
network it's not like that right you
need to go and then and then really and
then you need to process and they need
to make good on it and I last year when
I had the great privilege of being able
to spend a day with Jack Bogle and
that's an interesting story of how that
came about but I spent like two weeks
preparing and then probably three days
codifying all my notes after of what you
learned from this great man who only had
it turned out one year left to live and
and so if you get that I mean you need
to do it because that's how you get the
return on the who luck and it's also how
you honor them right you're not taking
their time you have to make good on what
the time they spend with you so I went
down there and I knocked on the door he
lived in this modest house you had a
picture it's this modest house in
Claremont and a little bit of paint
needed on the door
and knock on the door and nothing
happens and then finally he sort of
yellow aside wants me to be wants to be
patient he's kind of curmudgeonly and
that door flings open and there's Peter
and he grabs my hand and two of his he
says I'm so very pleased to meet you
please come inside and we wanted we
sapped and I have this still this image
of myself of you know this is the model
I still have in my mind of the next 30
years in many ways is to pattern after
that way he had some sense of grace but
also the simplicity he sat in a wicker
chair and a few years ago they had that
when they turned his house into a museum
they had the first ever wicker chair and
lecture where you get to sit and Peter's
with her chair and give a lecture and I
got to give the inaugural wicker chair
lakor's lecture it was it was a one end
of the chair felt really big by the way
it's it was Peter's chair and and so I
was always asking why didn't want to do
this work why do you want to pursue
these questions what you know and I kept
trying to ask him questions but he kept
asking me questions and then finally we
got to go to lunch and I got a chance to
start asking questions and and and I
asked him at that lunch which of his 26
books he was most proud of the next one
he did write ten more he was 86 and
years later when I again a great
privilege had the chance to keynote the
drucker centennial he died at 92 and
Claremont asked me to come and give a
keynote talk at his inaugural I mean it
is centennial of his birth and he was
born in 1909 and is actually I think
this this is on on YouTube they put it
up on YouTube that I went I said I want
to go see the shelf and and the shelf
was all of Peters books put out
chronologically based on
when he wrote the first editions and I
said we're on the shelf when he aged 65
the answer was when you pointed to it
one third of the way across the shelf oh
my god that's amazing isn't it
and and and after that they were so kind
they sent me a photograph of the shelf
which is kind of long version photograph
it kind of goes all the way across I
have it above my writing desk and I look
at it and I picture a little note that
you know I'm not 65 yet right I have a
picture a little note which is you are
here and it's about 25 percent of the
way across I don't know if I'll ever be
as prolific as Peter was but I'll share
with you what I think was there's so
many things that were great about Peter
but here's what I think was really great
people think he was a management thinker
and he was he was the greatest
management thinker of all time but as I
stood back and looked at all of his work
and tried to think about what he was
really doing I think he was in pursuit
of a giant question and the best way I
can articulate that question is how do
you make society both more productive
and more humane if you think about it
that is one of the great social
questions how do you make our society
both simultaneously more productive and
more humane and I think when you look at
across the arc of his life it was guided
by a gigantic beautiful beautiful
question thank you so much for that
story I just envisioning you seeing him
sitting in that chair and then later
sitting in the chair and how surreal
that must have felt it was surreal and I
and and in a way it almost felt no this
is Peter's chair although I recently
have started this thing around here were
what I describe is you know wicker chair
meetings I don't have a wicker chair but
I'll just sometimes meet with people you
know that just there's something with
cross paths and it's just like oh we're
gonna sit down and have tea for a little
while I think of those as wicker chair
conversations well I could spend the
next the next hour on more questions
about your experience with Peter
experiences I should say but I will go
read the foreword because I must have an
older edition I will go find the forward
with some of the lessons learned can you
give us one of the one of the things
that that whatever whatever comes to
mind
that that you learned from Peter if you
wouldn't mind sharing that and then I'll
share with you two actually there's so
many than ten of them but I won't do all
ten one is that don't make a hundred
decisions when one will do and the idea
of that is that the Peter belief that
you tend to think that you're making a
lot of different decisions but that
actually if you kind of strip it away
you can begin to realize that there that
a whole lot of decisions that look like
different decisions are really part of
the same category of a decision and that
what you want to do is to then be able
to say no I'm going to make one big
decision that will be replicated many
many times because it kind of
conceptually captures it so for example
a one version might be so in my own in
my own case right you get and I am sure
you encounter this too you get lots of
wonderful interesting invitations things
to go do this or to go do that or to
speak at this or whatever they're
wonderful I mean you never never being
grateful for those opportunities but you
have to be very selective about what you
do and so as I was struggling with how
do you decide which to do right when
you're gonna say no to most of them mean
they all can look like a series of
individual decisions but then actually
know there's actually a couple of
big decisions is it a great tournament
potential and will you learn something
okay that's like a meta decision and now
you can sort of strip away oh is always
like actually the question is is it a
great teaching moment possibility or is
it not it's very different then should I
go to Austin and do this event right or
should I meet with this person all right
those are they looked individual but
they're really part of a whole that's
one and you can think of that as you
know the simple thing like you know what
you wear give me God a thousand
different decisions or you could make
one big decision and wear the same thing
all the time I suppose the the second is
the one that and I've shared this with
some others but it's so powerful at the
end of that day with Peter I asked him
how I could pay him back and he said
first I had already paid him back
because he had learned and then he and
he I remember this was when we were
doing the Thelma and Louise thing they
really scared right we didn't know if
this is going to work and I was
launching out to try to do this
self-directed path and and genuinely
scared and Peter said to me he said but
I do have a request that you change your
question a little bit it seems to me you
spend a lot of time trying worrying
about if you're going to survive well
you will probably survive and you spend
too much time therapy be successful it's
the wrong question the question is how
to be useful and that was the last thing
you said that day he just got out of the
car and closed the door and walked away
those the the Peter Drucker mic drop but
you know I find that I go back to that
over and over and over again
and we have we have with many many many
avenues that we can go down hopefully
the
is not the first end last time that we
have a chance to have a conversation
like this but I want to define a term
that's come up a few times already now
and that is flywheel yep and you have a
monograph a new monograph which is out
turning the flywheel subtitle monograph
to a company good to grandpa but let's
start with the term flywheel itself what
is a flywheel so and and also describe
why I chose to put creative hours into
this because there's lots of other
things that are in the pipeline still
and things that haven't gotten out why
flywheel extension since the final
chapter already exists and good to great
what why would I then write a monograph
so so the the idea behind the flywheel
so we were looking at let's go back to a
good degree we're looking at that the
question was why do some companies make
the leap from good to great and others
right who were the same in the
comparison set a situation at moment in
time resources industry customers did
not right so it's always the difference
and when we went into it I had this bias
towards believing that a dramatic
transformation would happen in a
dramatic way and and sort of thinking
that there would be an aha moment a
miracle moment a point of breakthrough
you can really sort of see you know
there was this grand thing that happened
and that was sort of an assumption I
don't know if I had it so explicit but
it was kind of in my mind and then when
we started interviewing we were very
lucky because we got to interview all
the key executives many of whom are no
longer with us but that were that were
still alive that had been on those teams
when they made those leaps right so what
was it like when you were there what was
what was happening when you were there
we Co did all the research and so forth
and what are the questions was something
along the lines of how did you know you
know what was the point of breakthrough
or what was I and repeatedly we kept
getting a response which was I don't get
the question that's a stupid question
there wasn't it
there was no miracle moment there was no
moment of breakthrough I don't think it
was as dramatic as it sounds it was more
of a gradual process it was like an
awakening that kind of happened in steps
right we just got this over and over
again and began to dawn on me that the
way something really dramatic appears to
those nothing from the outside is
different than the way it feels to those
doing it on the inside and so it's like
if you're watching an egg right and and
nothing's happening it just looks like
an egg is just sitting there and all of
a sudden it cracks open and out jumps a
chicken well you could have a big thing
your radical transformation of egg into
chicken and visionary leader transforms
egg into chicken and right but what's it
look like from the chickens point of
view it's just kind of one more step
after a whole bunch of stuff that's been
happening inside the egg that you
couldn't see until it cracks open so we
were observing that the way worked and
the way it felt were different and the
way it sort of really happened on inside
even though you can see the inflection
on the outside the best analogy I could
come up with was it was a series of good
decisions supremely well executed taken
with disciplined thought that added up
one upon another over a very long period
of time to produce a great result and so
I had this image of pushing a giant
heavy flywheel and you start pushing it
in this intelligent and consistent
direction you start pushing on the
flywheel and after a lot of work you get
one giant slow creaky turn and then you
don't stop you keep pushing in that sort
of the direction of those three circles
we talked about earlier which we're
passionate about what could be best at
what drives our economic engine so it's
not random pushing and you eventually
get to terms and then you keep pushing
they eventually get four they start to
add upon each other and then eight and
16 and 32 and 64 and a hundred and a
thousand and then 10,000 and then a
hundred thousand then at some point all
that cumulative momentum all that
killeth sort of like this that you can
there's a breakthrough that happens but
how did it happen what was the one big
push that made it go
is a nonsense question it would be like
asking you know what was the one
investment that made Warren Buffett
Warren Buffett well that's a doesn't
make sense right so it's a cumulative
effect and so that and then we observed
in the comparison companies that they
bought into the idea of these sort of
dramatic moments or radical
transformations or you know cultural
revolutions or whenever Savior CEOs
anything that we're trying to jump to
break through and sort of one big step
rather than the building of the flywheel
and that was kind of a Doom loop and so
we wrote this chapter called the
flywheel and the doom loop which was
chapter 8 of good to great and and it
really kind of captured it was a really
neat chapter because it just sort of for
me turned out on its head about how it
actually happens and it came from the
research right it was all from the
research
so then after publishing could do great
and you know it changed our lives and
I'm very grateful for how many people it
reached but right around the time of its
publication in 2001 it was published in
October September October of 2001 I was
invited up to Amazon and the Firewheel
principle was embedded in good great
it's a fundamental principle of how you
know great companies get built over time
once it lasts and so forth and I knew
the principle and I was and I was there
with executives in Amazon and all I did
was teach right I don't just taught them
the principles then good to great and
particularly the flywheel coming out of
the dot-com it's like don't respond to
this as an event respond and build a
flywheel and great students are gonna
take things and make them even better
and what they did was they took the
flywheel and then made it their own
and what what they did was to say we're
gonna harness the flywheel principle
that came from good to great but we're
gonna do it by getting clear on what is
our flywheel and so to really harness
the flywheel then you have to be able to
say okay so but that's great the
flywheel principle is the principle but
how do you then turn that into your own
flywheel like what is the flywheel know
what the amazon people did kind of in a
more simplistic form but I'll
just grab it here essentially they they
had this sort of reinforcing loop right
you know if you lower prices on more
offerings well then you almost can't
help but go down to the next step on the
flywheel picture a circle going around
right to increase customer visits and if
you increase customer visits well then
you almost can't help but get more
third-party sellers and if you get more
third-party sellers well then you almost
can't help but expand the store and
extend distribution and if you do that
you can't help but grow revenues per
fixed costs and if you do that you can't
help but a little lower prices or more
offerings which is just going to attract
more customers is--is which is going to
attract third-party sellers which is
going to expand the store to extend
distribution you can eventually buy
Whole Foods and all the other stuff
you're going to grow revenues for fixed
costs and then BOOM lower prices on more
stuff etc etc now the beauty of that was
that they got very specific and what I
came to understand was the flywheel
principle best comes to life when you
can really capture but here's the key
people talk about flywheels you know we
have a flywheel whatever and what I came
to see is that people didn't necessarily
really have a flywheel because they
didn't understand something deeply
important about how flight what a
flywheel really is a flywheel is an
underlying compelling logic of momentum
it's not a list of steps drawn as a
circle call the flywheel rather there's
an inevitability built-in if you do earn
you almost can't help and if you do be
you almost can't help but do see and if
you do see you almost don't know but
doodie and if right and around around
and it gets driven around because
there's an underlying connection there's
a logical sequence that builds dynamic
momentum because a drives B Drive C
drives D and around back to the top of
the loop and that if you can kind of
stand back and then say we need to
engage in the very hard thinking of
figuring out
exactly how our flywheel turns what is
our flywheel in a way that truly has
that inexorable driving momentum within
and different organizations will have
different flywheels different people
will have different flywheels do you
have a flywheel right and and then the
key is you build it over a long period
of time and the power of a flywheel is
that it's an underlying logic it's it's
an underlying architecture it's not a
single business right it's something
that can be extended you can then extend
it into new things as you experiment and
find new things that will drive the
flywheel even further whether it be
going from military bombers to
commercial jetliners in the case of
Boeing but the same underlying
architecture going from memory chips to
micro processors in the case of Intel
but the same underlying architecture and
and so what the flywheel monograph is
about is basically after I'd like to say
to people just because you're the one
who articulated the principle as we did
in good to great we've we uncovered it
we articulated it and and it's right but
it doesn't mean you yet fully understand
it even if you're the one to bring it
forth after 15 17 years when we were
working on it I realized that my
understanding of the flywheel back and
good to great was right but primitive
and so this notion of really really
thinking through the specifics of a
flywheel became something that I really
wanted to share with people because I
felt that people were talking about it a
lot but not really understanding it and
so that's what that's about and just
just for people who may be wondering so
bye-bye Manik when you see a monograph
one way to think of this would be as a
short book it's I think 46 pages
yeah yeah 42 46 pages and in that you
also talk about you give other examples
and walk through Vanguard
Cleveland Clinic you did mention earlier
and I don't I don't know if if this is
in in the monograph as well
but possibly asking you about what your
flywheel is well I thought knowing you
that you might ask so I in my kind of
drive for being prepared I put a little
thought into that so I'd be happy to
chat about it let me just share with you
one thing though about the different
examples that I know they cover a wide
range we have an elementary school
principal unit to create results for
kids basically and you've got health
care and you've got startups and
whatever but why am on a monograph here
this is a McPhee I I hope would like
this idea a piece of writing has a
natural web a symphony has a length
Gimme Shelter by the stones has a like
you wouldn't say to give me well we
should make Gimme Shelter uh you know
seventy-two minute piece it's the wrong
light for you to filter mm-hmm and
writing is like music it has an
appropriate length to what the music is
trying to do to be and when I realize
back in 2005 when sometimes you can have
something that a powerful extension idea
or an idea it really shouldn't be a book
it's not enough pretty important yeah
100 percent agreed yeah but it shouldn't
be a but it shouldn't be just an article
because that's ephemeral because it's
doable right so we were really
struggling we wrote this thing called
good be graded in social sectors which
was another monograph and I was like
what are we gonna do with this if we
make it an article including perishable
and too short and we make it a book it's
too long and and then i weld you live in
a chapter in the back gonna go to great
well the problem that is then all the
millions of people have bought good
great bike need to buy another copy of
good to great that that's not right so
Joanne
my strategic brain said well why don't
we create a monograph and publish that
and started thinking about like member
common sense
think of the impact of common sense by
Thomas Paine it didn't have to be big it
was the right size and so I thought well
why don't we put him back there honor
okay the monogram top and so we wrote
goda great in the social sectors I
remember printing 50,000 copies and
thinking I don't have 15,000 prints but
give it to me what it won't sell and
then it putted it up
featuring lots of people we decided to
do one on the on the flywheel here so my
own flywheel if you want to chat about
that I'd be happy to take it kind of
describing it yes please when you do a
flywheel you need to first ask where's
the flywheel going to start so in the
case of Amazon it's an economic flywheel
for that ultimately brings stuff to more
customers and so forth it starts with
lower prices or more stuff right but
Cleveland Clinic begins with getting the
right medical professionals that can fit
in their culture Eurosport designer
intel starts with great innovative
products so the start of the flywheel is
a key question and in my case it's
curiosity fed big questions that's where
my flywheel starts it all starts with
what am i curious about that has to be
at the beginning of everything and if
I'm really curious about something well
then I can't help but want to learn
about it and do research on it and that
will throw me into the research if I do
the research right and really really
throw ourselves into it and stay on
those creative hours of the research
well then I can't help but have ideas
and insights concepts that come out of
that research and then if I have those
then I can't help but want to write them
and teach them and share them and and
that means going through the suffering
of writing right as you know right and
and and and to write them well and to
wrap them well and to get the concepts
in the right vessels I can't help but
want to do that and if I can't help if I
do that well then I can't help but have
at least some impact on the world if
it's well done because that's the power
of writing you never know where it goes
and if you have impact and reach in the
world well then you can't help but have
funding that comes from that meaning
there's some economics
that comes that allows you to do what
fun and feed your next curiosity big
questions which then leads to the
research which then leads to the chaos
two concepts which then leads to writing
and teaching which then leads to impact
on the world which then generates
funding which then allows me to fund the
next question and then it's perpetual is
it is it also the case that in some
cases I'm struggling with how to how to
ask this question because it just
occurred to me but I suppose it is that
is it as true that there are negative
flywheels as there are positive sort of
these vicious cycles that are
reinforcing within companies that people
should be aware of or is the flywheel as
you use it a virtuous cycle and also
looking at sort of disabling flywheels
that they might have organizationally so
the answer it's a great question and
actually I think it could be really
interesting to think about dysfunctional
flywheels right and really think about
those and I would offer two things the
first is that if a flywheel doesn't seem
to be working you have to kind of get
the diagnosis right because it could be
that the flywheel is just you haven't
got the flywheel right or it could be
that the flywheel is fine but think
about the inexorable logic imagine you
could score each of the five or six
components on how well you're doing it
say one to ten
and suppose your scores are eight nine
ten nine three nine well the very nature
of the flywheel the fact that it's the
reinforcing logic that builds incredible
momentum over time has a downside which
is that that three stops the whole
flywheel and so you have to be able to
say well maybe we have a flywheel that's
working it's a great flywheel but the
problem is we're not executing on this
piece of the flywheel and therefore the
entire flywheel stalls or stops so
that's an important thing for people to
think about you can't if you do five six
to the flywheel well you don't get five
six of the momentum you get none and
that's there
the downside of the flywheel because you
got execute on all of it now going to
this other question in good to great and
a lot of this concept came from good a
great which is why we go back to it a
lot that all the other books built to
last great by choice and so forth but in
good to great and then later we explored
it further in how the mighty fall which
is studying how great companies fall we
describe this other pattern we saw in
the comparison companies or in the
companies that fell which is a Doom loop
so you have the flywheel on one hand and
you have the doodles on the other side
and yes and the Doom loop though tends
to have the following pattern you are
grasping for some sort of salvation a
new Savior a new program a new strategy
a new direction a new right because
things aren't working and because it
really doesn't have underlying flywheel
logic to it it doesn't really get any
traction there's a burst of hope and and
well gosh you know maybe this will
really work and then that's false hopes
dashed by events and then that produces
kind of a reaction without really
understanding what really work which
then leads to another grasp for
salvation and what happens is you drive
yourself further and further down and
that grasping for salvation which is
stage four of five stages of one great
companies fall and that eventually leads
to companies really going to the bottom
so while you can have actually we
because yes again they always have the
comparisons the the good degrades and
the comparisons they're built to last in
the comparisons the comparisons often in
fact double down on a Doom loop and
drive themselves into the ground mmm
thank you for clarifying that
I have just just a few more questions
okay to go for another five to ten sure
you may want to sort of zoom out on
something else of just sheer curiosity
uh oh yes that's exactly where I'm going
and it is I've observed you to be in the
research for this in your writing also
in this conversation very data-driven
very methodical someone who trusts in
the data trusts in the data and there
are two things that I'd love for you to
put in context or explain for me which
are which which at least at first glance
don't seem to fit and it could be that
I'm miss perceiving who you are or it
could be that I'm miss perceiving how
things transpire the first is well that
they're there too that jumped out the
first is you having mentioned that you
got engaged
four days after your first date yeah the
sec the second was around 35 36 your
Thelma & Louise
moment where you it's you it seep yet
less than $10,000 in the bank and you
kind of threw this Hail Mary yeah those
both seem very out of character from us
so is it that you've looked at the
downsides decided you could survive and
you ran some type of calculus how did
these two things happen given that you
seem to be encoded to be very
data-driven to think through the
contingencies to test the assumptions
and so on and so forth so I think those
are related but very different
situations and I think they they one of
them is consistent with one of our
principles and one of them I don't know
where to put it so so what are the key
principles from all of our work is the
notion that life everything you have to
kind of great things bill by discipline
people discipline thought disciplined
action then building it to last and then
you multiply times return on luck Allah
Kel uck and it's and think by the way
the evidence is very clear the big
winners are not luckier we were able to
establish that advice by quantifying
luck and studying it the big winners get
a higher return on their luck than the
comparisons but they don't get more luck
per se now in and I've mentioned the
associate of who luck all the way
through our conversation and lessons
from great mentors one of the key things
we've learned in our works everything
starts with people discipline people but
also just people and I don't know how
you quantify certain aspects of just
things about people I mentioned earlier
friends in my marriage and I just you
know what
time with people you love meaningful
work with people you love and respect
and so with Joanne we found each other
we had we both came from families that
they were clearly not built to last
families and and we we met it
we met him bold or very briefly but we
really met in college at Stanford and
our first date was a run and I wasn't
really a runner but I really wanted to
be around Joanne but I couldn't I was
too shy really to ask her out but so she
eventually said to me I said to her so
you still running and she said yes
and I said well I'm thinking of upping
my mileage which was true because I had
just thought of it and talked about so
she said would you like to go for a run
and I said sure and I went over to her
dorm room and she took me out on an
eight mile run
oh you honor runs and it was anybody who
knows the Stanford campus knows that if
you go out sort of towards Page Mill
Road you go immediately uphill out of
campus so we went three miles uphill and
and then the sort of padua about the
three-mile mark it became very clear to
her I wasn't really that much of a
runner and so we walked five of the
eight and we got to know each other
really well and that was my senior year
in her junior year and by Thursday we
had simply decided to throw our lives in
together I don't know where the data
comes from that I don't know the
evidence I just had this sense and and
and and I think Joanne did too of this
this incredible stroke of luck that
these two people had I just I mean we
found each other and it was just an
instinctive thing and we just did it
it was truly and it's funny because
Joanne later was the the Nike athlete
she won the Ironman in 1985 she was a
the original just do it campaign so
maybe she was already thinking just do
it right what can I get married
so anyways and we got we got married
about six months later and I can't say
where the evidence comes on that but is
hands-down the best decision I ever made
and but then the key is the commitment
to make it work because relationships
are about I mean you just did the
unwavering we will not fail at this
marriage no matter what and you have to
have some place in your life you know in
in good to great I wrote in the
acknowledgments one of my favorite
paragraphs I've ever written and it's at
the end of the acknowledgments and I was
going to write about Joanne and I wrote
a line which is along the lines of
success in the end for me is that my
spouse likes and respects me ever more
as the years go by and I hope by that
measure to be as successful as she is so
I don't know where that comes from
yeah well you said at the very beginning
of this conversation or maybe you're
quoting Vince Donna can't recall but he
yes many of the most important things
are transcend the capabilities of
language right and this certainly seems
to fall into that category and in some
respects yeah the the big bet so one of
the things that we learned in great by
choice with my co-author Morton Hanson
another great stroke of who luck in my
life he's a tremendous is a genius
research methodologist and a great great
partner on great by choice one of the
things that we struggled with was the
role of big bets and the role of you
know kind of new directions and in
and so forth and one of the things that
we found is the importance of empirical
validation which is really different
than pure analysis and the two principle
we called fire bullets than fire
cannonballs and the idea being you have
a certain amount of gunpowder and emit
and you have a ship bearing down on you
and imagine you take all that gunpowder
and you put it in a big cannonball and
you fire at that ship and it misses and
you turn and you look back and you're at
a gun powder and now you're in real
trouble but imagine if instead what you
did was you you fired bullets and you
fire your first bullet and it's 30
degrees off and then you take another
buddy gunpowder and you fire the second
bullet and it's it shoots out there and
you're now you're only 10 degrees off
and then you take a third bullet and you
fire and you put it in and it hits the
side of the ship ping you know you have
a calibrated line of sight and now you
take your gunpowder whatever you have
and you put it in a cannonball and
you've fired on the calibrated line of
sight and what we learned is that and
I'll tie this into the Ellen Louie's
moment because what we learned in our
research is that one way you extend a
flywheel is you're firing bullets and
then every once a while get calibration
and then you fire a big cannonball on a
calibrated line of sight which then adds
a big burst of momentum into a whole new
direct not necessarily new direction
because the fly wheels turning but it
gives you an empirically validated big
bet that can give you massive momentum
and the key there is notice though it's
empirical validation and that empirical
validation are the bullets if we go back
to the Thelma and Louise moment there is
the moment of gulp when you fire the
cannonball right I mean you can't just
sit there only fire bullets there comes
a point when you got to fire the
Cannonball in that case I was really
scared because if the Cannonball didn't
hit I didn't know what was going to
happen we were really felt out there but
there were also six or seven years of
bullets that had been the research we
had done the teaching in the classroom
and also some early response to built to
last there's no guarantees yet but early
response of people
really resonating with the ideas right
there the there it wasn't like it just
came out of the blue there were bullet
bullet bullet there was enough
calibration that this was not crazy the
question was would we have the guts at
that moment then to take all of our
gunpowder put it into a one big
cannonball and to go and there's a
critical lesson I got from one of my
mentors another stroke of wholock at
Stanford two great professors that were
there with me when I was teaching bill
lazier who taught me about the
importance of relationships first in
life and there was this guy named Irv
Groesbeck and I asked herb do you think
I should keep enough capital alive here
at Stanford that if this doesn't work
out I could come back and Irv said to me
an option to come back has negative
value and I said I thought options
always have positive value he said no
not on a creative path to really that's
such an important plan exactly he said
if you have the option to come back
it will change your behavior and you're
doing a low odds game which means you
you have to put all in 100% full
Canabalt going off that cliff otherwise
you're gonna hold something in reserve
and when it gets really scary you're
gonna pull back option is not in your
interest so we took all the Gunpowder
and fired it out and there was no
retreat and then when you're making the
decisions you're out there like how are
we going to get the car to the other
side and the the Thelma and Louise jump
well there's no tether back you have to
make it and the good news is you've done
a hell of a lot of calibration over six
to seven years exactly just just to
underscore for people out there like I'm
quitting my job yeah this moment it's
like well wait and hold on correct there
it wasn't recording the ships aspect to
it but it was very calibrated very
calibrated I I don't know about the four
days but the rest was calibrated
[Laughter]
well I was calibrated to just perhaps
not with your prefrontal cortex as much
right there's a lot lot
well you might we could we could talk
about if we could talk about dive into
that another time but I mean there's
thinking fast thinking slow there's
there's there's a lot to decision-making
only part of which is is part of what
we're able to express with with language
but what a story Jim this has been so
much fun I highly encourage people to
read all of your work but the newest and
I think this is a very variable I don't
think I mean it is a very important
concept the flywheel and the expansion
upon that so turning the flywheel people
can find that everywhere books are sold
they can certainly find you at Jim
Collins comm many more questions I'd
love to ask sometime but I think this is
a very solid session for me to reflect
on I have tons of notes sitting here in
front of me I have been trying to take
my notes quietly but is there anything
else you'd like to say ask if people
suggest any any parting words before we
wrap up this conversation for now if I
were to kind of step way back on
everything there's a line that Joanne
uses a lot which is life as people and
we've talked about who lock great
mentors and personal boards of directors
and getting married after four days and
great friendships and being on really
great level five teams and whatever but
you know we get so wrapped up in all
these things were doing or things were
trying to get done but the life is
really short I mean you know that you
named your company after on the guy who
wrote it
shortness of life and and you know and
you sort of add it all up the one thing
I with everything we've talked about in
this I still think it all goes back to
the first who life is people at life at
its best is about
doing meaningful things with people you
love here here time with loved ones high
simplicity time to flow state ultimately
it's the people and Jim is there
anywhere online besides Jim Collins comm
where people might learn more about
where you're up to or say hello are you
on this amazing yet sometimes dreadful
technology sometimes referred to as
social media I'm firing bullets I'm
gonna be I fired the people as I'm gonna
fire some at this point I haven't done a
lot with it
so I'm kind of in the calibration stage
and the question I go back to on that
with the social media is I've been
struggling member I said earlier you
know don't make a thousand decisions
well what are one will do what I have
been struggling with is how if I were to
use that tool do I make it great
teaching moments and for me if I can
kind of bullet to cannonball to that
then I'll probably do more with it and
if I can't well I've been fine without
doing a lot mm-hmm and where are you
currently firing firing bullets than I
have I have some thoughts but is it on
on Twitter is it elsewhere there's we
have a twitter account which i think is
called level 5 leaders it is at level 5
leaders at level 5 leaders we have a Jim
Collins Facebook page where a me on my
team helps me think about some postings
but we haven't put up a lot so I
wouldn't encourage that there's
necessarily a ton there at the moment
we're be firing bullets stay tuned
but our website Jim Collins calm
everything there is designed to share
and teach the ideas and it's all really
built around the ideas when you go there
you know it's it's it's an ideas driven
website and we've taken a lot of care to
try to make it a place where students of
the work can come and have almost like
cyber cyber office hours if you will and
and really learn and that
when it's designed to do so I will say
just a few things relate to social media
yeah that's so the first is I've seen
some incredible thinkers who have done a
lot of deep work go down in flames
after tapping the vein with social media
so I would say caution is warranted that
would be my first observation the
because you have a history of saying no
so well and you have so many policies
that have served you in providing the
space for the joyful solitude of deep
work so I would just say be very careful
and I was gonna say when you're talking
about burning your bridges that someone
had said to me no there there's three
there are three addictions that are the
most dangerous addictions of all heroin
alcohol and a monthly salary but I would
I would add to that social media there
there are however some examples and I'll
just give you one of people who I think
do an exceptional job of teaching using
short form and there's one person on
Twitter there are many but I'll point to
one who's a close friend of mine his
name is navall rava Conte and his handle
is at navall and a VA L like Naval
Academy but at Nepal so he would he
might be someone to check out but so
people can follow you at at level five
liters we will link to four people
listening all of these various sites all
of the work including of course during
the flywheel in the show notes as always
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
you can just search jim collins in this
episode and all of its notes will pop
right up Jim this has been such a
pleasure and has given me so much to
think about and I'm so so grateful for
having spent the last two hours with you
well I I'm actually very grateful as
well and and I you're right I don't
actually say yes to very much at all
I've only fired bullets in this genre
and and this is one there's like I'm
gonna commit to really preparing and
having a good conversation with you and
part of it is because what I really
learned about you is the care and depth
of your preparation
and at the fact that then you come into
it with the idea of really wanting to
have a conversation where you are
present and engage with ideas and with
thoughts and and and so you know that
notion of of prepared curiosity I think
is a great strength and to be able to
join you in that for me is a real
pleasure and we're going to count at
least half of this as creative hours
definitely absolutely and this podcast
is certainly I have to figure out which
which piece of the puzzle are should say
rather which component of the flywheel
it is but as it is certainly somewhere
here because I feel drawn inevitably to
have or to strive for this type of
conversation and it just gives me so
much joy to be able to spend time with
someone like you and share it with with
everyone listening so thank you again
for that and to everyone listening you
can find links notes for everything it
teamed up log forward slash podcast for
all of the goodies that we discussed in
this episode and until next time thank
you for tuning in hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday and
that provides a little morsel of fun for
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in with your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it this episode
is brought to you by peloton which I've
been using it for about a year now
peloton is a cutting-edge indoor cycling
bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home you can also do
on-demand which is what I do we'll come
back to that so you don't have to worry
about fitting classes into a busy
schedule or making it to a studio or gym
with a hectic or unpredictable commute I
for instance have a peloton bike right
in my master bedroom at home and it's
one of the first things I do many
mornings I wake up I meditate for a bit
then I knock out a short 20 minute ride
in my undies part do that at the gym
take a shower and I'm in higher gear for
the rest of the day it's really
convenient and has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say
low-impact versus high intensity or
interval you can pick the class
structure and style that works for you
and in my case I quite like Matt
Wilbur's and I tend to do on-demand and
listen to a lot of and watch many of the
same classes over and over but I'm kind
of promiscuous and also enjoy classes
from a lot of the other instructors they
have peloton an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles and
personalities so you can find what
you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or in any way and Santa buys
me but they really 100% hit the nail on
the head I was very very impressed with
how motivating it was and it worked
tremendously to keep me push
which quite honestly takes a fair amount
I can get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out
discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings a studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one pallet on
Comm that's full and e peloton PBL OTO
and calm and enter the code Tim all caps
at checkout and get $100 off of
accessories with your policy on bike
purchase so get a great workout of home
anytime you want check it out go to one
peloton calm and use the code Tim to get
started this episode of the Tim Ferriss
show is brought to you by linked in the
write higher can make a huge impact on
your business the wrong tire can create
your business and I have seen example
after example from thousands of my
readers at a minimum where they have
told these stories of how finding the
right person at the right time and in
some cases not even asking what should I
do
but asking who should I find because
that person can help me determine what
exactly to do more intelligently and
I've had a chance to hire two such
people in the last year and that has
just made my business take a quantum
leap forward and my complexity in my
personal and business life get cut
dramatically in this type of
certification cannot be overvalued you
think a lot about hiring and I think a
lot about hiring and it is a skill that
I've had to learn it is important to
find the right person but where do you
find that person you can post a job on a
job board and hope that that right
person finds your job that they are on
the internet happening to scan something
here and there and then find you but
think about it how often do you hang out
on job boards the answer is probably not
so don't leave finding someone great to
chance when you can post your job
exactly where people go everyday to make
connections grow in their careers and
discover job opportunities that is
linked in most LinkedIn members haven't
recently visited the top job boards but
nine out of ten members are open to new
opportunities and with 70 percent of the
u.s. workforce on LinkedIn posting there
is the best way to get your job
opportunity in front of more of the
right people and you can be very very
highly targeted and specific people who
are qualified for the role you have and
ready for something new this is where
you find it it's the best way to find
that person that you person will help
you grow your business this is why a new
hire is made every 10 seconds using
LinkedIn that's bonkers every 10 seconds
so head to linkedin.com forward slash
tim and get $50 off your first job post
that's a linkedin.com forward slash tim
t IM to get $50 off your first jobless
linkedin comm forward slash tim take a
look
terms and conditions be
[Applause]
you
you